but fast sounds serious like something
you would call someone you don't like I
kind of feel as though it's really gonna
give up like really quickly
it looks really cheap but then there's
also this is like a little I like a
monastry here and it's made by monks so
it's good for the soul and the body
tonic wine I don't know what even that
mean it feels like when they came up
with the label I don't know how long ago
there's never changed it high caffeine
content contains sulfites this sounds so
healthy so here we go oh that is not a
nice color
it's hard to relax my face after that it
was like really beacon like cough syrup
II its cough syrup mixed with
blackcurrant juice it's not that bad
I like this I really like that that is
like a really nice kind of port it kind
of tastes like Christmas like spices and
fruitcake to like bad sangria
you've got Jagermeister and you put like
red wine in it and then let it out for
like six days the fact that it has
caffeine in it I feel this would have
been the vodka redbull for 40 years ago
I didn't taste the caffeine but I
definitely felt it and it's the thing
that's gonna kick you on into four or
five in the morning is this legal very
warming its kind of relaxing I really
like it you can feel it going all the
way down your esophagus and kind of just
warming up different parts of you it
kind of tastes like how your grandma's
house smells I would drink that for
breakfast because it's refreshing and
it's got a bit of a kick to it it's 15%
alcohol when you can't taste it in that
so that's like the perfect drink I love
this I really want this in Australia it
really smells bad though if this is what
the Scottish teens are drinking to get
that really quick Cheers
you don't want her team bachelors from
here
buck-buck whiz but school buckfast i got
there in the end that's great